welcome back to six at $0.99 artificial
general intelligence today we have mark
raybert he is the he really doesn't need
an introduction but we'll give him one
anyway he's the founder and CEO CEO of
Boston Dynamics he founded the CMU like
lab in 1980 the MIT leg lab in 1986
Boston Dynamics in 1992 he and his team
have developed some of the most amazing
robots ever built including Big Dawg
Atlas handle spot spot mini these robots
move with the agility dexterity and even
grace that rivals and often supersedes
that of human movement he continues to
inspire us with what robots are capable
of achieving in the real world and what
physical form future intelligence
systems may take as they become
integrated in our daily lives so please
give mark a warm welcome
[Applause]
this is our grand mission our aspiration
which is to make robots that are equal
to or greater than people and animals
and it's you know it's a daunting
mission because we're so good at things
it seems effortless you know I'm
standing here knowing questions that I
could stand here like this but a lots
going on I can manipulate things I can
pick up this water or I could reach in
my pocket and use my hands with all the
sensors in my hands and coordinate that
and maybe most of all our perception
systems you know this audience has what
is it 250 people in it or something and
I can look out there and see every one
of you stabilized in space even while
I'm moving it's it's just astounding and
you know robots aren't there yet but I
think they can be and our goal is to
keep chipping away to try and get there
before I get started I wanted to say
that I got my start in robotics here at
MIT I was a graduate student I was in
the what was then called the psychology
department the brain and cognitive
sciences department but I was taking an
AI AP course just like you are and it
might have been you know exactly this
time of year
when I followed one that my professor
Burt old horn back I had so I was
jabbering away out I'm asking him some
question about this or that and we
walked back to tech square which is
where the AI lab was in those days and
we went up to the ninth floor and
Russell nafse Kerr who was a guy working
in the lab had an arm all taken apart on
the table it was like a thousand pieces
and I was a roboticist from that day on
I swear I didn't switch my major but I
you know got Burt old to be an advisor I
found a topic that had to do with
robotics in that time it was a
manipulation thing but eventually became
legged thing and it was amazing you know
and I've never looked back
so here are some animals doing things
that are very exciting climbing around
on very rough terrain very sure-footed
using a mixture of their proprioception
and their vision and look there's even a
baby that probably is only a couple of
months old has no trouble at all doing
these things and look at the Grace and
suppleness and the fearlessness of these
animals it's amazing here are animals
running for their lives the Gazelle is
trying to stay alive for the next ten
minutes and the cheetah is trying to get
a meal so that it can stay alive in
general sorry and you know even people
can do things that a breath take I
assume all of you were out this morning
getting a little exercise climbing up
the green building that we're in now and
and maybe the other places around here
it's funny I bumped into some people
when I came into the room who were
climbing the stairways I think they were
going on a trek up and down them but I'd
like to see the going outside so
probably most of you have seen this
video this is uh this is sort of where
we were after about ten years of work
attempting to make machines that could
work out in the real world that were
dynamically stabilized dynamics is a big
deal for our company and for what we do
so some active sensing and control and
understanding of the physics here this
robot has all its control onboard and it
has reflexes and sensors and this is an
extension to a thousand-pound robot that
could carry about 400 pounds of payload
and we took it all around the United
States testing it in various situations
here we have it in Virginia doing some
bushwhacking it's actually following a
person but the person is only in that of
you intermittently so it has to be able
to keep track of where the person is and
deal with that and then back in good old
Boston ten inches of snow
just marches right up the hill here's
the cheetah now you know MIT has its own
cheetah this is our cheetah the people
know song Bay who was doing the MIT
cheetah a very dynamic machine and
basically an experiment in seeing how
fast we could make something like this
run although you notice it's on a
parking lot so it wasn't doing this on
rough terrain and getting both the
efficiency and the speed in in the
context of a machine they'd also can do
rough terrain is a really big challenge
that remains with us so this is just a
snapshot of most of the robots that
we've built at Boston Dynamics over the
years and I'm not going to talk about
most of them I'm just going to talk
about the last four these are all robots
that we developed since we've been part
of Google which has been the last four
years spot mini there's a spot mini on
the floor here which will demo a little
later spot Atlas the humanoid some of
you may remember the humanoid that we
used in the DARPA Robotics Challenge you
have one here and and then handle which
is our latest version so I'll say have a
few words to say about each of them so
we had been developing a big dog and
those other quadrupeds that I showed you
for quite some number of years and it
was amazing for us to find out when we
did this project on on spot this is the
predecessor to that that there was still
a lot to learn and we kind of
revolutionized the hardware design and
how the control worked and got a much
higher level of rough terrain
performance and part of the solution to
that was to be able to decompose the
control problem into many separate
controllers that operated in different
regions of state space and that allowed
us both to have programmers work on
multiple solutions to the problem and
also have the complexity of each
controller simplified by only having to
operate in a small part of the dynamic
space
here we've added a robot arm to the to
the previous version of spot and you
know we believe that mobile manipulation
that is manipulation when you can move
the base is really a powerful way of
doing things now this is probably the
most important thing I want to show
tonight and I'll show it three different
times the idea that we don't build
controllers that just do one particular
thing but that they can determine where
they are in the execution here's another
version of it and then adjust what
they're doing in order to compensate for
disturbances in the real world I know
this class is about AI and probably
autonomy I think that the one of the
most important ways of getting to
autonomy is to have the low level
implementations very robust to
disturbances so that the planning steps
don't have to take care of all the
minutiae of the details of the real
world and that's what we've been trying
to do there we've been experimenting
with doing delivery of packages to
people's houses these are all employees
of Boston Dynamics so we didn't go
crashing ordinary people's houses and it
turns out that there's just lots of
different kinds of stairways and
entranceways and the robots doing very
well we're up to something between
seventy and eighty percent of of the
kinds of stairs and access places we
encounter after collecting data and
making improvements and adjustments so
I'm going to say if
you philosophical things or approach
things a lot of people think that this
is the model of how a computer and a
robot interact that is there's the robot
which is hardware and electronics and
sensors and and then there's a computer
and that the computer listens to the
sensors on the robot and then gives it
instructions and tells it what to do and
well I think that's actually going on
there's another part to the story which
is that the physical world is also
giving instructions to the robot and
that means that the energy is stored in
the robot either in its Springs or in
its it's motion those are all important
determinants of how the robots going to
behave in the time coming forward and so
we like to think in terms of designing
the hardware of the robot the physical
world and the computer all as one
holistic thing where we take into
account those interactions sometimes we
call this a harmony you know a harmonic
system is one usually where you have
energy oscillating back and forth almost
all legged locomotion has some amount of
harmony going on between potential
energy of elevation potential energy of
elastic deformation kinetic energy of
motion and you know inverted pendulum
things and the like another part of our
approach we call build it break it fix
it now I have friends who build their
robots and are so into the the beauty of
what they've created that they kind of
put it on an altar and afraid of
actually hurting it so in fact I even
have friends here at MIT that have done
that where they have a gold-plated robot
and they're afraid of taking it out into
the world I mean we're just the opposite
every one of our robots is designed to
get bashed to bits we have staff who are
there to fix the robot on a daily basis
as we break it and I think doing that
build it break it fix it means that
we're able to learn a lot from the
actual physical robot working in the
world and we can use that knowledge in
order to improve the robot improve its
behavior and we really like to go around
that loop as quickly and as we can early
in the in the process and do it as many
times as we can so here's what build it
break it fix it looks like this is in
Somerville
our engineers this is um a Boston driver
now this robots supposed to be using its
visual system to avoid the trees I think
it might have fallen in love with this
tree
we don't purposely give them any emotion
but boy it's hard not to see that and
here's the first time we tested the the
push response to this robot hey did you
hear that
that's the new guy's car so some guy we
just started that week Trent had $5,000
which we paid for in in repairs to his a
vintage BMW so the last thing sort of
about philosophy is long-term versus
short-term you know our company is 25
years old and we've mostly been a
long-term robotics company that is we're
interested in moving the boundary
forward in what what robots can do and
we're interested in you know making it
so robots meet the dream of being the
equal or better than people and animals
but now we've started function
[Music]
okay we still on can you hear me but
lately we've started to realize that
some of our robots have enough
capability that maybe it's time to try
and productize them and we will learn a
lot by doing that too one of the things
for instance that I've always claimed is
that we always spent a lot of money on
building our robots in them and use that
as a competitive advantage that is DARPA
was a frequent funder of us DARPA always
said let's take money out of the
equation and just figure out you know
how to get the solution and then worry
about getting the cost down later so I
always assumed and argued that once we
get a robot doing things that are
interesting then you can go and redesign
it to make it lower cost well we're
going we're going to test that because
it might not be true it might be that
we've designed ourselves into an
expensive corner and that it might be
too late but the robot that was showing
a little bit is much significantly cost
reduced from the prototype of it and
it'll be interesting to see whether we
could get it down to the kind of prices
that are useful so this is just a
picture again of the idea of aiming long
but also aiming short and I think it's
going to be a challenge to see whether
we can keep the culture of the company
to support both of these directions
because people manufacturing stuff have
a different mindset than people trying
to get out to the future horizons and
it's going to be a challenge to keep
both those kinds of people happy here's
some of the things that some of the
kinds of applications you can look at
based on modest technical capabilities
I've shown mobility and manipulation
here but you could put cost reliability
there's many things that could be on
these axes
you know entertainment like robots and
theme parks is something that I think we
should be able to do I already talked
about home delivery I think home
delivery is waiting for self-driving
cars to get all the way there self
driving trucks and once they do then we
will be working on getting it from the
truck to the to the home logistics
there's about a trillion boxes moved
every year around the world and most of
it's done by hand and so there's really
a big opportunity to having robots help
with moving those trillion boxes
security which could mean either
commercial security like patrolling your
shopping center or the military type
security construction a lot of people
have been coming to us with their
construction applications asking if we
can help and you know I'm not going to
talk about it now but if afterwards you
want to ask about that I can fill you in
a little more and I think this is really
the ultimate home run application care
for the elderly and the disabled I used
to say that I wanted to have robots that
would help me take care of my my parents
and older people but I realize now that
it's probably going to be my children
using them to help take care of me but
you guys all you're all a little bit
younger and I think there'll be a time
when you could use robots to help make
your parents lives better now some of
you may think that your parents don't
want that but I think it's a complex
question we've seen some surveys that
say that you know people aren't totally
happy with the idea of their kids taking
care of them on a moment-by-moment basis
and I think there's going to be an
opportunity for doing something but
technically this is still a ways off
it's it's a tough thing okay let's get
back to the robots
spot Mini is a robot that weighs about
60 pounds that previous spot weighed
about 180 pounds this one weighs about
60 pounds and here's some Anatomy it's
got an arm with five degrees of freedom
each leg has three degrees of freedom
it's got about a 500 watt our battery
batteries for these things are a
challenge because you know
can have consumer products like electric
drills that have relatively small
batteries and then there's electric cars
that have big batteries and there's not
really much available in between so
we've done a lot of work on the battery
technology for these things to make them
safe and reliable and hot swappable and
things like that then there's radios and
computers the previous version had three
quad core i7s this one has two we're
trying to cut back on the cost and then
there can be some sensors lidar s stereo
and the like so you can see spot minis a
little bit smaller than spot this isn't
a real house and those aren't real
people those are engineers this is
inside of a warehouse we have out on 128
where we've built the house you can see
that they don't we don't mind scuffing
up the walls here and there is a lot of
scuffing that happens some of you may
recognize ACTU Kowski who's a an MIT
alum and he's again disturbing the robot
here the robots using its vision to do
some stepping stone type operations and
I think gene is going to talk a little
bit more about this in a couple of
minutes and here's a case where it's
doing stepping stones on real stones and
it's keeping its balance figuring out
where to put the feet and again this
robot only has stereo looking out the
front whereas this one has stereo on all
four sides
now one of the cool things about animals
is that they have these stabilization
mechanisms for their sensors that was a
real chicken no robotics involved and
here's our attempt to show that these
this robot can do the same sort of thing
and if you think about it when you're
manipulating you really want the hand to
be stabilized in space and so you'd like
the body to be able to kind of
coordinate with the hands so that you
can concentrate on what the world
real-world task is man
you guys didn't pick up the banana peel
huh so our concept for the spot mini
product is to make a platform it's sort
of the we're thinking of it like the
Android of robots so with Android
there's a hardware platform and then
there's a software platform and then
developers third-party developers create
their own apps that use the platform so
we've made this spot so that there's a
place to mount hardware on the robot but
there's also an API to program it
through and then there's a facility to
have additional computing external to
the robot and we're working with third
parties to develop their own
applications that run on the platform
this is a video that we haven't been
able to release publicly please don't
tape it and show it because I can't I'll
explain later if you want to know why
not but this is just a revealing that we
do have an arm on the new version of
spot
it's using a camera in the hand to find
the the door handle this robot doesn't
weigh a lot so it has to use tricks to
keep the door open so that's why puts
his foot in the door and here again we
want to show that the we've made the
solution robust to certain kinds of
disturbances so Andy there Andy sitting
over here is pushing on the door pushing
on the hand the robot keeps track of how
far how much progress that's made in
doing its task it's so it's so smart it
even kicks that that shell out of the
way now that was a total accident and
now it's just going back to try again
okay and then this is a demo of autonomy
here the robot has in a previous session
we've taken it around the lab this is
Boston Dynamics taking them around the
lab and recorded visual data that could
be used for navigation and it's using
its stereo to match up features in the
environment so that it can navigate and
go where it had gone in the previous on
the previous path so there's no one
driving it for this it's all autonomous
that was outside my office every day
around noon the robot seems to show up
and I hear it pausing out there I don't
know why it turned there sometimes it
comes up with a solution that isn't in
here you'll see another one it comes up
with a solution that isn't quite
what you call is an optimization but it
does it does get a solution so we're
pretty excited by this we call this
patroller out and we're working on
developing a lot of software to support
it to make it so that other people can
capture a patrol route and then execute
them on a on a routine basis and then do
two other tasks while they're on the on
the patrol route Seth you're on so we're
at will do a demo of spot mini so for
these for this demo Seth's got a
joystick and he's telling it the speed
to go in the forward direction and
turning but the robots doing all its own
gate selection coordination of legs
balance obviously so the robot has a
bunch of different gates it can walk
here it's doing one leg at a time it can
trot I know you do whatever gates you
want except he's got to use a selective
so here's trotting which is diagonal
pairs of legs it can do pacing which is
lateral pairs of legs to get working
together I have to tell you in the
earliest days of me being involved in
legged locomotion
I thought gait was a big deal but it's
really kind of a small thing and I don't
think it's central to what matters which
is support stability propulsion and
things like that I'm gonna wrap up
shortly I just thought I'd say a couple
of words about the mechanical side you
know the Atlas is a new version of a
humanoid I know some of you worked with
the DARPA Robotics Challenge humanoid
which was a big hulking thing that we
made and this is a much more svelte one
and the way we got there was to work on
the elements of the mechanical design to
take advantage of 3d printing and some
optimization and we did we focused on
two or three different things one is
making some of the leg parts where we
embed hydraulic pathways hydraulic
actuators places for valve mounts and
filters and things like that into the
leg and this is what that looks like
there's a single upper leg part that
incorporated about 15 or 20 different
separate components in the previous
design which made it lighter more
compact and higher strength to weight
ratio we also developed a hydraulic
power unit which takes many components
the thing on the left are the components
as separate ones and we were able to
print up parts that integrated them so
that there was a motor a pump inside of
a motor an accumulator reservoir valves
filters and those things and we shrunk
it down so that the robot could be
smaller and lighter and using that
approach we went from about a 375 pound
DRC robot to a 190 pound robot and then
the current one is about 165 pounds now
this picture might lead you to believe
that I'm advertising myself is only
weighing 165 pounds and I'm fortunately
that's not true but I'm working on it
but it is close to my size and weight
and I don't know I don't think we have
this out as a video here's some robot
behavior that uses whole body motion
meaning the mobility base plus the arms
plus the torso are all combining in
order to handle these these boxes it's
using vision with the QR codes to
simplify the task here we're trying to
go at human speeds of operation and so
the robot searches for a box using its
vision
I think that I think that was the only
take we ever got with both robots
working together and you know one of the
problems with YouTube is everybody's
already seen what you've been up to by
the time you get it go around to give a
talk so I imagine most of you have seen
this but here's a parkour robot we're
working on where we've actually
strengthened the hips so that it can do
a little bit more jumping and and it's a
kind of interesting that we've been
interested in making a robot a little
bit like the humanoid that has less
degrees of freedom fewer degrees of
freedom and the simpler and we designed
this robot and the ultimate version of
this we'll have about 10 joints whereas
the humanoid had 28 and have many many
of the same capabilities we have some
use cases for this that I'm not going to
talk about today but this robot can lift
heavy loads it has a relatively small
footprint given what its strength is so
the way things are done in logistics now
is to use big robot arms that take up a
lot of floor area or heavy and we're
looking at ways of using a robot like
this one not exactly this we it's sort
of any evolution of this design in order
to do logistics operations so I want to
make a pitch to you Boston Dynamics is
hiring and I hope some of you will apply
for a job there these are how many is it
6 x 3 these are 18 MIT alum that
currently work at the company many of
them for many years so I'm sort of
making the point that these people are
happy they're just like just like you
could be and I hope you'll look at our
website
and see what we're what we're looking
for and considerate so I'm just gonna
wrap up by talking about you know I used
to be a professor here and at Carnegie
Mellon and when I was the professor
we used to mostly wrote papers and we
were excited by you know how many papers
we could write and how many people cited
them in their papers but as a company
guy instead of papers I think we count
YouTube hits and instead of citations
here I want to tell you what this is but
most of you probably know
so now we count now we count spoofs
instead of citations and I'm happy to
say that we're doing great we have about
about two dozen BigDog spoofs here's
four of them and the upper left is in
Akihabara Japan the upper right is a Los
Angeles online television show
it's the Netherlands on the lower left
and I guess that's Appalachia on the
right the poor kid doesn't even have a
friend to to be in his movie well what
about what about Atlas can you hear that
[Music]
here's it here's another one
[Applause]
so we have we have a big crew working on
all these projects you've you've gotten
to meet a couple of them here but it's
really quite a team in a an absolute
pleasure to work with so anyway thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for the presentation it was
amazing
what sort of physics simulation like if
any do you have in your robots and do
you really think that like with the
current trend of neural networks we can
just like do end-to-end modeling of
these robots with like without any sort
of notion of physics but just like
neural networks so we have simulators
that we've worked on for a long time
very detailed in some cases validated
validated me and compare the behavior of
the simulator to the physics of ground
truth and you know I think they're
important for our work and we use them
frequently but the end to end doesn't
ring quite true
usually the when we use simulation the
user is knowledgeable about the
trade-offs between doing a physical
experiment and doing a simulated
experiment and they're usually getting
at some specific where specific setup
question rather than the idea that you
start at one end you know - at least in
our experience trying to simulate all
the subtleties of the hydraulic actuator
back lashing gears flexibility
you know the non rigidity in the
components that's a big undertaking and
usually so so distracting that you can't
really get on with with what you're
doing so I think we use experiment for
those subtleties and we use simulation
for bigger level dynamics questions hey
would you say mechanical concerns or
computational capability is more of a
difficulty in terms of determining how
quickly you can perform tasks with the
robots you know we like to say that
they're equally important we we now
although we didn't start out this way we
now have equal strength in our groups in
the mechanical design and implementation
and in the software and controls and
sensing and I think you know they all
matter I think if you try and get by
with just marginally designed hardware
you don't get my
experimental time in because the things
broken all the time so even though we
are rough on our machines they mostly
keep working because because we've put a
lot of you know attention to detail and
how they're designed but you know
there's still that I think perception is
still a tall pole in the tent certainly
if you want a rival human perception I
don't think we're you know were anywhere
near there I think the self-driving car
stuff is helping there's a lot of
interesting things happen there I think
specialized Hardware skating you know
Asics and and things that could help but
you know it's it's all still needed so
you guys have developed like various
components that all kind of they'll come
together to build one robot have you
seen applications for any of these
separate components elsewhere so organic
design for example for the Atlas maybe
prosthetics or hip replacements or
something like that because there seems
to be a lot of development going on and
then individually as well as the big
picture I mean you're asking a very good
question there's a question in case
people couldn't hear is aside from value
to the whole robot of the components
we're making are the components useful
some other way and you know the place
where we think it's probably most true
is the specialized hydraulic components
we've made servo valves and the HPU
I'm sure we could sell them into other
industry I as a company focus question
though that's really what it comes to do
we really want to be doing that will
that absorb too much time and attention
and personnel or do we want to you know
our heart is really in building you know
future generations of robots so I think
we're going to probably stay there okay
thanks
I was wondering have you done any
research in regards to getting the
robots to perform tasks involving direct
physical contact with humans
I can only the only thing we've done is
we've done teleoperation which is not
what you mean where we have a human
moving in the robot you know copying
which is very interesting because you
can see that that's a way of showing how
fast the robot can be and how
coordinated it can be using a human and
for part of the computing but we have we
don't have them interacting with people
I guess the closest is we once did a
thing where a person and a robot picked
up a stretcher and work together to pick
up the stretcher but they weren't
touching each other they were going
through the stretcher material
do we have plans ah you know we're
really to be honest we're really
struggling with coming up with some
strong concepts for safety even without
doing that you know robots it's you know
your first reactor stree action and how
you make a robot safe if there's a
problem don't really work very well you
can't freeze the robot you have to find
some you have to keep them going find a
way to get into a safer state so I think
having them in contact with people is
just going to be harder so eventually we
want to to help you know to carry lift
the elderly and things like that but
we're not there yet my questions about
the relative rates of progress in
robotics and machine intelligence so an
economist might maybe measure it by
seeing how much money is going into
computing hardware versus arms and leg
sensors and actuators that kind of thing
so on one impossible scenario the the
machine intelligence rushes ahead and
the robots progressing more slowly
because of kind of slow build test cycle
basically it's their real-world things
it's not so easy to get a rapid build
test cycle with a robot and in and in
the other scenario the robots more
advanced than the machine intelligence
because machine intelligence is just
such a conceptually difficult problem so
in one scenario the machines are telling
the humans what to do in the other
scenario that he
telling the machines watch do if you
like so do you have any kind of
perspective on that whole issue of them
is that the machine intelligence folk
going to rush ahead being what's the
guys struggling behind or the robots
going to get there before the massive
problem and machine intelligence gets
solved or maybe somewhere in the middle
I think let's see I don't know exactly
what you mean by machine intelligence
are you talking about
you know having Google do better search
computation in general so I start I
talked about economists measuring
sensors actuators and compute Hardware
so that's the kind of thinking about
yeah I think that it's always been a
misconception that the hardware
components by themselves constitute
progress in intelligence or in robot
behavior they're I think they're
important ingredients but by themselves
you know when I was a graduate student
here I can remember reading an ad for an
optical character recognition system and
what the ad said was you know we have
camera we have a thing for holding the
paper you're looking at all you have to
do is write the software so it was all
done except for you got to write the
software and you know it's the the whole
problem was there so I don't know if I'm
answering your question
you know robotics is hard I think it
feels like we're making progress if you
keep pushing we keep making progress
it's not like there's an e and the curve
that we've hit but I also think that the
rest of the AI world is making a good
progress too and it's fun being a part
of it
hi I
my question is mostly related to
security so since you are productizing
your robots now there has been research
on Leiter's mainly where you could spoof
a lidar and
and the sensor basically cannot see
anything so are you looking into that as
well taking into consideration these
awesome robots that you're building
could be in let's say you know defense
you know working for the defense as well
so those are like really harsh
environments yeah I mean these are very
hard problems you know if someone if if
an intelligent adversary wants to trick
the robot it's not all that hard these
days you know where we're working
probably the other end of the problem
you know trying to do the basics right
now I don't think you know I don't I
don't think robots are going to be as
autonomous in a hostile environment
as as people either think or fear
because of how frail they'll still be
until we get further along hi there Hey
I want to ask about two things that are
going to probably play a big role in
adoption the first is price so if you
could speak to the current unit price of
a spot many and how that you think is
going to evolve over time and the second
is sort of consumer psychology I felt
like when I saw the the test at the end
of the robots wearing my level of
comfort with it being in my house
suddenly shot up
it seemed way more human so I was
thinking about what kinds of experiment
you guys were on where you what you've
thought about with respect to making
people more comfortable with robots
working around them yeah in terms of
cost all I you know we're not saying
what this thing costs yet but we will
later in the year we have reduced the
cost of this by about a factor of 10
from what the first prototypes cost so
we're making progress in terms of the
psychology of robots it's been very
interesting to watch you know we we got
branded sort of as robot abusers because
we kick with our robot really what we
were doing was trying to show how good
they were at balancing and we weren't we
didn't think we were abusing them I have
video of me pushing on my daughter when
she's one years old and actually
knocking her over
but that wasn't my goal I wanted to kind
of test out her her balance and I bet
you you know if you guys have kids or
you're at all that you've you've done
stuff like that so but we've adjusted a
little bit and so we don't usually push
on the robots in our videos despite the
one we showed with the hockey and the
hockey sticking hand on this thing
that's why we had the banana peels as a
way to have the robot crash without us
being having our finger prints on it you
know I I guess the other data point I
have is that if you look at the likes
and dislikes on our YouTube videos we
found a way to get the likes to dislikes
ratio much higher by partly probably by
not looking like we're abusing the the
robots there's probably a long way to go
to make these things really friendly and
I have to admit there's a little
spirited of our cut at our company of
being kind of you know it's fun being
bad boys in terms of you know just make
the robot do cool stuff and leave the
the emotions to others and certainly the
social robots that have so much going
into making them cute I don't know I'm
sure we'll have marketing people working
on that I don't know what else to say hi
general questions so in terms of
research purpose or like practical
purpose so what are the reasons that we
choose to investigate on these humanoid
robots so it seems like it cannot run as
fast as the cheetah and it also cannot
carry as many stuff as the big dog yeah
you're you're basically saying that the
humanoids don't seem to be as practical
in terms of functional right so is it
more efficient like like a humanoid
robots more efficient than they start
cheetahs and the big dogs well you know
the motivate so I don't have a good
answer the motivation for the DRC the
DARPA Robotics Challenge which
humanoid robots was to say that they
wanted to use robots that could go the
places designed for humans and and so
that's why they used the human form and
I think you know there's an argument
there it is true that the human form has
a lot of complexity to it because you
have very complicated legs in the biped
and they're supporting the weight of the
body and the arms whereas the quadrupeds
can spread all that out so I'm
sympathetic to your question I don't
really have an answer I can tell you
that the public's reaction to a humanoid
robot is off the scale compared to
anything we've done with Quadra Petro
BOTS for what that's worth so we always
get a lot of viewership if we show a
humanoid doing something but I think
it's a question that we will keep
addressing we are going to keep pushing
on getting the humanoid to do more and
more human-like things even though we
probably won't commercialize them as
soon as we commercialize the other stuff
how do you specify goals and although
you said earlier that it's expensive to
do like simulations and stuff
do you have any intentions of doing any
deep reinforcement learning what was the
last thing I do you have any intentions
of doing deep reinforcement learning
I'll do the last one first we I'm sure
we will use learning before too long I'm
not sure whether it'll be deep
reinforcement learning or something else
but mostly we're interested in
optimizing the complicated state space
partitioning we do right now we use you
know people make very simple decisions
as to how to divide up the space and we
think that these things could probably
be really improved if we use the
learning approach so that's probably the
first place we will apply it we do a
little bit of learning here and there
but not much compared to how much
learning is talking about out there what
was the other question
how do we specify a goal you mean to the
robot or how do we decide as a company
so I don't think there's any
across-the-board answer we write
applications for instant for each of
these uses so for instance in the where
we were doing the patrol route we have
an application that has a UI that lets
the user you know tell it the
information it needs it can tell it to
go ahead and start on the patrol and
things like that for for the door I
think I think there's a button on the on
the controller we can show you
afterwards if you want and you walk the
robot up to the door were you steering
it and then you press the button and
then it starts looking for the door
handle and it goes through the hole you
know goes through the door but I don't
think these answers are fundamental I
think you could do it lots of different
ways
you know we're working on all the
machinery coming up from the bottom to
be able to do these things and then you
know in some case you could have it be
buttons on an 8 on a UI it could be an
API that's accessed through some
higher-level ai and we just aren't
sweating that part of it at this point
hi so aside from locomotion I can use my
body for like you know nonverbal
communication to communicate my
intentions and and other such things
even though I'm not always aware of it
and I guess I'm wondering if this is
something that you've considered for
these robots I think the closest we've
come is having the robot go like this
after the flip which was a way of
communicating we really haven't been
anything along those lines I'll bet you
though the people writing code can
interpret a lot of the subtleties of
what's you know what's working and what
isn't by looking at things like that but
the robot isn't trying to communicate
that way
I have two questions um how do you make
the robots really how do you make the
robots really fast how do we make them
fast no my question is how did you make
them fast I mean like the time how we
get a lot of people who are really smart
and good at working together with each
other at our lab and then they make
plans and we everybody tries to stay on
the plan and then you know pull it
together sometimes it doesn't go as fast
as we like especially if we have to buy
parts from someone else and they're slow
that happens a lot no honestly is that
what you mean so we don't make them that
fast you know we're pretty fast you know
usually four or five months to build a
new robot something like that but mostly
it's getting people to work together
what's it what's the other question dad
that question is why do the people push
the robots why did it why do they push
why do they push we're trying the robots
are always balancing them themselves and
so we want to show that they're that
they can balance by by showing that when
you knock them they still they don't
fall over they stay up on their feet so
we're kind of showing off
are you building anything why not I
don't know you should um let's way off
why way off where is the base I'm not
good at building no yes yes you are you
might think you're not well some games
there are you had to give it a try and
you're the right a you're the right age
to get started I'm six and a half
perfect
[Applause]
would that I think please give the mark
a big hand
thank you very much
[Applause]